bom dia a todos e todas pra mim eu tenho
um pouco de fato de louco
eu acho que na verdade todos nós temos
um pouco a loucura dentro da gente de
fato está acontecendo a copa do mundo é
e de hoje essa imagem é é uma das
imagens que hoje temos no brasil é eu
como como muitos outros brasileiros
eu faço parte de 50% dos brasileiros que
não está torcendo pra copa
eu estou é e até muito estranho falar
isso porque eu sou brasileiro sou
patriota
amo meu país é eu sou extremamente
apaixonado pelo meu país mas hoje eu não
torço pra copa
eu acredito que estamos no momento de
repensar o que vem acontecendo com esse
mundo estamos num momento de repensar é
de todas essas grandes organizações
eu falo que estamos num momento de
repensar o papel das nações unidas que
estamos num momento de repensar a
própria fifa que estamos num momento de
repensar esse mundo e essas grandes
estruturas que existem
tá certo é essa a minha foto o
fotojornalista tá bom é mas a photon
costumo dizer que a fotografia não me
defini é apenas um caminho que encontrei
para que eu possa levar minha pátria
minha voz para que eu possa lutar é uma
forma de militância é eu tive a honra é
essa revista é a revista veja no brasil
é considerado uma dança revista mais
importante da américa latina essa minha
foto foi para o mundo inteiro sobre os
protestos do brasil e pra mim os
protestos de um como joana como
jornalista como fotógrafo como militante
de direitos humanos que eu sou
foi muito emblemático ao mesmo tempo em
que eu vi com muitas pessoas saindo para
as ruas lutando é que no brasil que eles
dizem que o gigante acordou e
e eu fiz esse registro dessa foto e foi
propor uma das maiores revistas do país
e rodou o mundo mas ao mesmo tempo é
você está numa grande imprensa você está
trabalhando num grande veículo e que ele
geralmente não conta a verdade ele é
omitir fatos ou ele deixa de contar
algumas versões sobre este fato então no
brasil nós vivemos também este dilema é
qual quem está com a verdade quem está
falando a verdade
se você coloca uma e essa pra mim essa
foto linda ela foi interessante porque
ela ela não graças a deus que ela não
deturpou na verdade a mensagem que eu
queria passar e e às vezes a fotografia
é isso que tipo de foto que você tá tá
fazendo o que o qual é a sua verdade que
você está construindo qual o caminho que
você está tomando o que você está
construindo pra que essa sociedade possa
mudar pra que esse mundo possa mudar
quem é você qual o seu valor com a sua
identidade com sua identidade de nação
com a sua identidade do ser humano com a
sua identidade de família com as quais
são seus amigos
como que você constrói um outro mundo
como que você constrói um mundo melhor
um mundo onde nós possamos dialogar
onde nós possamos compartilhar
informações onde nós possamos conhecer
um pouco do outro conhecer essa cultura
e pra mim é muito interessante que eu
quero falar um pouco também dessa dessa
realidade que nós estamos vivendo no
brasil que é a questão dos protestos que
a questão da busca pela democracia
ah ah ah ah estava até conversando com
um amigo que ele disse poxa mas no
brasil vocês tiveram grande avanço é e
de fato tivemos grandes avanços nos
últimos 10 anos tivemos várias políticas
estruturantes políticas como o
bolsa-família políticas como de é
políticas de acesso à educação por
exemplo só fiz uma universidade porque
foi possível através de um programa do
governo e eu fazia universidade
se eu contar mais ou menos 11 anos atrás
10 10 e 11 anos atrás eu não tinha nem a
passagem de ônibus pra tomar pra ir pra
pra falar pra escola aliás não tinha
passagem de ônibus pra ir pra escola eu
fiquei mais de dez anos
estudar eu fiquei mais de 10 anos se
estudar um dia eu era um aluno muito
revoltado
tá certo eu não me via na escola eu não
me via dentro eu não me sentia
representado dentro da educação como
amiga acabou de dizer não me sinto
representado em educação e e e piora
briguento dava muito trabalho dentro da
escola
brigava com o professor brigava com o
aluno é eu não tinha o dinheiro para
comer o mesmo lanche com meu colega
tinha ele ia de uma vila com a lancheria
tudo arrumadinho tudo bonitinho vai
deixar a vida na porta da escola eu não
tinha o meu pai para me levar na porta
da escola
eu não tinha minha mãe para me levar na
porta da escola parece que isso é
bobagem mas isso faz uma diferença
fundamental
eu não tinha meus pais para ir nas
reuniões da escola sempre quem ia me
representar era tia do orfanato onde eu
morava e é muito interessante isso e às
vezes quando ia e então a educação ela é
foi construído de uma maneira diferente
eu disse eu não consigo não lidava com
dinheiro então não sabia por exemplo o
preço do valor de um pão
eu não sabia o preço das coisas eu não
sabia é que porque as coisas vão
chegando pra você e você não sabe de
onde vêm qual caminho por exemplo você
sabe o café da manhã hoje você tomou
quem tomou de onde vêm e quem os
produziu qual foi o custo e esse custo
que você está pagando hoje eh eh eh eh
bom é ruim quanto o produtor quem
produzir o café
você sabe quanto ele está ganhando você
sabe quanto aquela pessoa que estava
servindo café pra você ganhou quanto com
a qual o custo disso daí dentro disso é
só no meu questionamento
a professora me disse o seguinte é você
não vai dar em nada na vida a falar pra
mim você não vai dar em nada na vida
mas é interessante porque eu acreditei
em kut isso se uma professora ela falou
isso pra vocês uma mãe falou isso pra
você você acaba em curtindo isso entra
dentro de você
eu já me gera revoltado já não tinha
meus pais
tá certo e mais agravante ainda é que na
instituição as pessoas que eram pra
cuidar de mim zelar pela minha dignidade
dizia lá pelo meu desenvolvimento
intelectual eu é que estava que era para
resguardar é eu sofria abuso sexual
dentro dessa da unidade onde eu morava
também então se imagina como que ficou
na cabeça de um jovem negro no país que
tem que que há uma desigualdade
econômica muito grande mas também há um
grande problema da questão racial
você engorda você fica louco na segunda
instituição eu fui para a rua o que
viver minha vida fui morar na rua e eu
vivi quatro anos morando na rua na
cidade de campinas em são paulo e
conheci de tudo conhece todos os tipos
de pessoas com esse todo tipo de
realidade
conheci pessoas que fumavam crack com
esse pessoas que vendiam droga conheci
pessoas que cometiam assaltos que
cometiam vários delitos e também só que
era interessante assim que mesmo no
submundo que mesmo na criminalidade que
mesmo né e dentro de toda essa
desigualdade
sempre há pessoas boas você sempre vai
encontrar pessoas boas você sempre vai
pensar a sério é muito louco
você sempre vai encontrar pessoas que
sonham pessoas que estão ali naquela
situação porque deixaram de sonhar
porque outras pessoas deixaram de
acreditar
eu tive sorte de que várias pessoas que
acreditaram em mim olha que legal
eu tive sorte de pessoas muito simples
porque às vezes a gente olha fala
sinpoci fulano de tal
ele tem grana ele tem condições correndo
bem vestido ele anos um bom ter ele tem
carro ele é doutor e e às vezes essa
pessoa ela fala sim por ele pode
resolver o problema do mundo possui
fulano de tal
ele é doutor em ciências ele entrou pólo
fila ele é filósofo ele é tem pós
doutorado tem todas essas classificações
que esse mundo é exige da gente ele pode
resolver o problema do mundo mas eu vou
falar pra vocês só vocês estão todos
errados equivocado se acreditarem nisso
porque na verdade a solução estão nas
pessoas e pessoas simples e pessoas que
muitas vezes não aparece na televisão e
pessoas que não estão na mídia e pessoas
que não que não que não que que muitas
vezes pessoas não dão nem atenção a
transformação do mundo está nessas
pessoas pessoas simples
eu tive a última oportunidade de se
amado dentro de todas essas mazelas
eu fui amado é a primeira pessoa que me
levou pra morar na casa dela ela tinha
dois filhos homens e três filhas
mulheres ela pouco se importou se
entendeu quem eu era
pouco se importou da da minha realidade
ela me viu no portão da casa dela a
frase olha entre que meu filho você vai
tomar um banho
eu vou te dar roupa ea partir de hoje
vai morar aqui dentro da minha casa
ela não se preocupou nem com as filhas
delas ela falasse olha eu confio em você
e eu e deus está pedindo para que eu
faço isso para você ele falou assim tá
no meu coração e eu vou fazer isso para
você ela era uma empregada doméstica
tá certo não tinha mais condições de
alimentar todos os filhos era separada e
me deu essa oportunidade e hoje eu estou
aqui agora eu gostaria que voltasse um
pouco por gentileza
essas fotos durante as manifestações
é eu percebi que o seguinte que por mais
que eu estava publicando na grande
imprensa que a minha foto estava saindo
no mundo inteiro mas não é isso que a
gente está em busca não é isso quando eu
acredito fala assim porque como
fotógrafo oficial podia falar por
realizado como a foto saiu em todos os
jornais do mundo eu estou ocupando o
espaço na mídia que eu gostaria que eu
sempre sonhei com a faculdade de
jornalismo me trouxe isso me deu essa
possibilidade mas daí eu percebi que era
necessário fazer um pouco mais ou
criamos é tem como voltar aquela foto
uma foto de quetta eu e uma galera e
isso essa galera aqui ó
essa galera aqui ó eu conheci eles
durante as manifestações olha que louco
e e você a uma identidade
tá certo eu fui lá e essa galera também
estavam fazendo coberturas mas não pra
imprensa normal fazer uma cobertura
independente para publicar no facebook
para publicar na internet sobre vários
casos de violações de direitos humanos
durante as manifestações e eu a gente
acabou conhecendo essas coisas que a
vida dá oportunidade e nos tornamos
amigos e criamos fundamos o carranca
pode passar aqui com a gente lá no rio
de janeiro pode passar e nós começamos a
fazer o que a produzir material
diferente que é pra mídia então por
exemplo ia para uma cobertura fazia
fotos da manifestação mas dependendo se
houve grande violência da polícia se
ouve é k grande casos de violações de
direitos humanos
e eu sei que a mídia não vai dar eu
mandava pra eles no facebook então antes
mesmo de o mandar para o jornal a foto
que vai ser um jornal que vai ser na
internet de você abrir mão um pouco de
que você tem pra compartilhar para que
outras pessoas possam ter seus direitos
respeitados então pra mim não era mais
importante vender a foto mais importante
pra mim era que essas fotos chegassem às
autoridades que o governo vice é a
situação que estava acontecendo então a
gente passou a publicar no facebook
passou a publicar na internet pode
passando essas fotos casos de várias
revelações e ela tem tom preto porque a
gente começou a atacar também a
construir
as narrativas que fotojornalismo é esse
que você sempre mantém aquele padrão se
entender da polícia sempre no ou sempre
uma na perspectiva de cima para baixo e
e essa idéia por exemplo é uma das fotos
que teve uma desocupação por conta da
copa pode passando então a gente começou
a mostrar um outro mundo a gente começou
a mostrar um outro um outro
fotojornalismo através do carranca pode
passando e também brincar com as
palavras e fazer um pouco de haiti um
jornalismo mais artístico mas tudo
através do facebook pode parar
chique né foi assim por aquele cara lá
o relógio é cruel é é interessante essa
foto aqui é é emblemática
mas ao mesmo tempo ela pra mim ela tem
outro significado é o seguinte mais ou
menos no ano de 2003 um pouco antes de
entrar na faculdade é no meu bairro
acontecia vários casos de violações de
direitos humanos a polícia extremamente
violência e eu eu tentei eu não tinha
mal terminado o ensino médio
eu ia à biblioteca pegava alguns livros
sobre direitos humanos que sempre me
interessei por essa área e queria
entender o que é o como que podia lutar
para que essas violações parassem para
que essas violações e saci para que a
gente conseguisse denunciar à polícia
que a gente conseguisse denunciar o
governo mas não só pela violência
policial mas pela falta de saneamento
básico pela falta de direito à
alimentação pela falta de estrutura pela
falta de moradia vários problemas que o
que eu sentia na comunidade eu
participava da associação de moradores
quando era necessário fechar uma rua
pública por conta do esgoto estava
correndo a céu aberto a gente ajudava
protestava ajudava é pra quê pra que as
autoridades nos ouvissem e eu e no
evento que o fim de direitos humanos eu
conheci uma organização não
governamental
essa organização e essa organização foi
muito bacana tópico aprendi um pouco
mais eu participei de um colóquio depois
de um certo tempo eu percebi o seguinte
que as organizações as grandes
organizações não governamentais
eles estão como as estruturas como a
fifa como as nações unidas
e como há a organização dos estados
americanos
elas se tornam grandes se torna big
empresas elas se tornam mega corporações
infelizmente muitas organizações não
governamentais e mesmo que defende
direitos humanos se tornam mega
corporações e eu descobri o seguinte que
essas organizações
elas têm o poder de pautar as nações
unidas ela tem o poder de pautar a
organização de estados americanos
e quando se fala em faltar é significa o
seguinte que elas ditam qual vai ser o
tema do ano o tema da água o tema do
meio ambiente
o tema dos povos e e elas uma infinidade
de temas que a gente ver fla se valesse
o nível da água funciona as nações
unidas vai estar dando dinheiro para tal
tema as grandes organizações
internacionais
elas vão está abrindo editais e
financiamento para tal tema e eu percebi
que é o seguinte as organiza ele estão
dando dinheiro
só que muitas vezes isso não vem com a
realidade dos países
tacetti fosse apontar discutindo sobre a
água sem entender o tema da água tal vai
aonde vai premiar a fota vai fazer isso
vai fazer aquilo
só que a minha realidade é que há água
nem chega na porta de casa como que faço
tem que buscar água
não sei aonde ou então um problema que
está no meu país é diferente do problema
que está acontecendo por exemplo aqui em
angola eu tenho um outro problema por
exemplo de segurança pública no brasil
que é necessário discutir políticas
efetivas no brasil de participação
coletiva para que se discuta por exemplo
a polícia pacificadora e o tema é água
então eu descobri que é não é sério é
insano é verdade é verdade e eles
decidem globalmente olha que loucura
existindo globalmente então por exemplo
se você tem uma outra realidade é outra
necessidade no país você não consegue
aí eu falei o seguinte eu quero
participar
eu quero entrar para dentro desse
esquema só que eu percebi que as
organizações estão estruturadas são
cadeias é como uma grande corporação
senão vai chegar lá se você não vai
falar com o gerente geral do banco se
entender por quê
nunca vai te receber o frio assim é
então que eu vou fazer eu vou criar
minha própria organização reuniu uma
galera e criamos a united rede
internacional de direitos humanos
tá certo nem na organização de estados
americanos não sabe que foi um grupo de
meninos que criou a organização
o que acontece hoje eu tô dentro da uea
ajudando há também a tentar mudar essa
agenda a tentar mudar para que os países
para que a áfrica ásia e américa latina
os países é que estão abaixo do de
mistério noite porque essas agendas são
dominada pelo pela europa são dominado
pelo pelos estados unidos são dominados
por esses países desenvolvido em tão o
foi o mecanismo que nós criamos e hoje a
gente levou quatro anos para ser aceito
pela aiea
mas hoje eu participo da sociedade civil
para de alguma maneira tentar dialogar
de alguma maneira pressionar e conversar
com outros países contra os membros para
que a gente possa de fato cada vez mais
que não só a agenda mas que os recursos
e que as discussões venha de encontro
com as nossas necessidades
aí está um pouco do meu trabalho muito
obrigado desculpas eu passei
olha a cantar